- Welcome.
(audience cheering)
I hugged y'all earlier so
y'all didn't have to get up.
So it's nice to meet y'all, all of you.
I've never met any of you.
So is this the first
time you're back together
since shooting the movie?
- We did. Key West.
- No, we got to go to Key West.
- Yeah, we did some (indistinct) together.
- They came to Key West.
- A few weeks ago.
- My hometown.
- [Kelly] Oh, so you got to-
- And we did a wonderful screening there.
- A whole screening there. That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Judy has a bookstore there.
- And a theater that she
built from the ground up.
Not with her own bare hands.
- That's exciting.
- [Rachel] But, you know (indistinct).
- You would be so multi-talented
if you built the theater yourself.
- I'm sorry. I did not.
- No, that's incredible.
Was that important to you?
To be able to give back to the community?
- It was wonderful.
- [Kelly] It's wonderful.
- I mean, this event was
giving to the community.
- Yeah. But I just mean
the theater in general.
That's cool. The bookstore.
- [Judy] Yeah.
- That's awesome for a community to have
that kind of like vibe,
like just to where you
could come together.
I love that you did that.
So we have to start with the story.
So you published this in 1970.
So did you feel then that it was something
that was gonna take off like it did,
or were you just doing you?
- You have to be kidding, like,
I didn't know what I
was doing, let alone...
- You had no idea?
- No.
- That's hilarious.
- I had no idea. I just let it out.
- Yeah. 50 years later we're
still talking about it.
- And here it is.
- That's incredible.
So what were your
experiences with the book?
You're very young.
So did you read this for the movie?
Or had you already read?
- I actually hadn't read it before.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I got the audition for it,
but as soon as I read the book
I remember going to my parents
and I was like, oh my gosh,
how did someone write
down this experience?
This is it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- How did someone write this down?
Oh, and it's all a credit to you.
- 'Cause you're like there,
you're experiencing it.
Yeah.
- Yeah. And I, as soon as I
started the audition process
and started filming, I was going through
the exact same stuff that Margaret was.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like at the exact same time
that I was shooting the movie.
So I think it came for me at
the perfect time in my life.
- Yeah.
- Because I could draw on a lot of my own
awkward, messy, weird experiences
as I was exploring
Margaret's character as well.
- Yeah. Puberty is rough.
(guests laughing)
Rach, it was not great for me.
What about you?
Did you read this when you were younger?
- I didn't.
I read a lot of Judy's stuff.
I love the Fudge series.
I read a lot of her
books when I was younger,
but I hadn't read Margaret.
I was like, oh, this about
boobs and things like,
(Judy laughing)
and I think I was seven when
it came on my radar, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All my friend's older
sisters who were like 10
were reading it and I
was like, oh one day.
I didn't realize I would be
like 40 when that one day came.
(Judy laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- And I'd be playing
Margaret's mom, you know?
I mean, that's just still blows my mind.
Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love it.
- So when I-
- It's such a pop culture thing. Yeah.
- It really is.
So when I did finally read
it for the film, you know,
there were so many great nuggets
for my character in there
and it was great to read it as
a mom about to play this mom.
But what I also loved is that
I related so much to Margaret, you know.
I was like, oh, I see why this is such
- [Kelly] Mm-hmm.
- a timeless story.
I just went right back to my childhood
in all the feels and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And yeah, it just really packed a punch.
- Yeah. A lot of things change in life.
Not puberty.
- Nope.
(everyone laughing)
- Just sucks at any generation.
It's just hard.
But you've played moms before,
but now you're a mom playing a mom.
Was that different for you?
- Yeah, I think I was
more relaxed about it.
I was always worried-
- Put more pressure when
you didn't have kids.
Am I doing this right?
- didn't have kids when
I was playing moms.
I was like, oh, I'm missing
something, I'm sure of it.
You know, it's like,
your idea of being a mom is so different
from the real thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So yeah.
I think I didn't do as much
mom research. (laughing)
- Yeah.
Well, I think when you
figure out you are mom,
no one's got it figured out, so.
- Right. Exactly.
Yeah. It's a crapshoot.
Just get out there and try.
- (laughing) Try, try your best.
Go for that green participation ribbon.
So did you have a hand in the casting?
- I did the whole thing.
No, no, I'm kidding.
No. You know, casting
belonged to the director.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Really, and Kelly and I
developed a wonderful relationship
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And a wonderful working relationship.
But casting was hers.
But she would send me tapes
and when she found Margaret,
she knew instantly that
she found Margaret.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And she told me, she said,
I don't want to embarrass you.
I'm sending you this
tape. And she is Margaret.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love it.
- And she was Margaret.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she is Margaret.
- Aw.
- [Kelly] Do you feel like-
- Which is me, you know,
because I'm Margaret.
- I know, I was gonna say,
is that the character in the story
that you relate to, like still?
Is that the one you kind
of relate to the most?
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- I am Margaret.
- I mean, I was Margaret.
- Yeah.
- Not totally.
- It wasn't like a biography,
but yes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, not totally.
- Yeah.
- But, you know, I mean,
that's the girl I was.
- Yeah.
- But so many of the
things I would tell kids
when they asked me about
Margaret, I would say,
well now you know my secrets.
- (laughing) Yeah. It's all out there.
(guests laughing)
- Some of them anyway.
- I have always been
amazed with how well Rachel
cries and talks at the
same time in movies.
(Rachel laughing)
This is not a joke.
(audience laughing)
I'm not just saying
- (indistinct)
- this right now.
I, just on this show alone, we have proof,
but I've said it many a times in life.
Here's the tape.
I wish I could like Rachel
McAdams cry from The Notebook,
but it's just not in the cards.
- It's not reality.
- Yeah.
- It's not.
- That's not real.
I just need a minute. I'm so sorry.
I can't talk when I cry. I'm
not Rachel McAdams. (sniffling)
(everyone laughing)
I can't, I can't.
- You look good.
- Yeah, totally.
- Nothing is dripping.
- Not everyone looks great crying.
- You don't look like Giuliani at all.
(Kelly laughing)
- I also don't look like Rachel
McAdams from The Notebook.
So I'm trying to handle it.
(everyone laughing)
(wind whooshing)
(audience cheering)
- I'm not kidding.
I say it all the-
- (laughing) Oh my god.
- Because you know what
it is? I'm angry about it.
(Kelly laughing)
Like, I don't understand how you do that.
(Rachel laughing)
Like, you have this thing where you cry
and still look beautiful and it's gross.
It's like what?
- It's so disgusting.
- Like your ugly cry is still
unbelievably cute and sexy.
I don't get it.
(Rachel laughing)
What are you, why?
Like how do you do that?
How do you hold your face together?
- I practice
(Kelly laughing)
in front of a mirror.
- Okay.
- For a really long time.
- No, I'm teaching a Masterclass in-
- (laughing) Crying
- Pretty crying.
I don't know. I don't feel
like it is pretty, but-
- Oh my God.
- And I think you look gorgeous.
- It's adorable.
You're lying. And I love you for it.
(audience laughing)
It's just one of those things
I was like, oh my gosh,
she comes on here, we
have to talk about this.
It's literally, I say it everywhere.
- [Rachel] That's so funny.
- Because it's one of those
things I feel like is rare.
Even like the greatest
actors think about movie.
You're like, not everybody
looks great crying
- But if you grew up watching
Demi Moore in Ghosts.
- Oh, I did.
- You know, that tear
- [Kelly] The one tear.
- here where
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- nothing else is moving.
Like the act-, you know,
that's an actress's,
Like, oh,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- if I can get that to Mecca.
- Don't worry. You're there.
Yeah. It's upsetting to the rest of us.
(Rachel laughing)
It's like, wait, I look like a hot mess.
Like, is she all right?
Like, that's how I look, anyway.
(audience applauding)
So Rachel, do you remember going through
those adolescent moments
that, I don't know,
Margaret goes through it in the movie?
You still, I mean, I know the
trauma is still kind of there.
- Yeah, it's fresh.
- Like I just, I had, let me tell you,
braces, glasses, acne.
Like literally everything
that could go wrong
was happening with me.
- [Rachel] Right.
- Like, did you?
Just lie to me and tell
me you had that existence?
(Rachel laughing)
Like, don't say it was perfect.
I will throw this pillow at you.
(hand thudding)
- Nope. Definitely far from perfect.
Yeah. So awkward.
And am I normal? Am I like everyone else?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, just hair, so much hair drama.
I chopped all my hair off
when I was in grade seven
and I would spend hours every morning
trying to make it work.
- Yeah.
- And then I'd walk to school
in a blizzard in Canada
and it would be like
(raspberry blowing), you know?
- Bobby pins.
- Bobby pins. You needed bobby pins.
This is a joke because an
early line in the book.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Margaret's trying to hold her hair up.
She's letting it grow back.
It was, she cut it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's the bobby pins.
- Bobby pins.
And then when I started seeing the cuts,
it's like, oh my God.
They never-
- Bobby pins everywhere.
- They never take-
- Always in my hair.
- the bobby pins out of her hair.
- We had to meticulously place them
in the exact same spot
every single day on set.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Judy] She has bobby pins-
- Continuity. Wow.
- Continuity. Yeah. It was insane.
- That's hard.
But Abby how do you think social
media affects all of this?
'Cause we didn't grow up in that. Like-
- Yeah, honestly...
- You know, that came out later for us.
- I think it does have a big influence
on these conversations.
It does.
Because we see, every single day,
we see all of these people and images
that are kind of falsified
in planting false information
in our brains and like creating a standard
that we're never gonna
be able to live up to.
And I think that, especially
at this time where
we have social media and
also the conversation
around periods and boobs
and bras and all this stuff
is kind of being censored in a way.
- [Kelly] Hmm.
- And I think we really need
to have these conversations
because it's super important
that we talk about this
because a lot of people go through it.
And it's important to
know that you're not alone
and it's important to
have actual information.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That is-
- [Kelly] The correct information.
- the correct information. Yeah. And-
- I learned on a school bus.
- [Abby] Oh God.
- It was not correct.
(everyone laughing)
It was kinda' weird.
So Rachel, when you were
just a little younger
than Margaret, you wanted to
be a professional ice skater,
which I did not know.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- For a second. For a second.
- I had to bring it up.
I was like, that's like
something we all dreamed
but never actually did.
Like, but you did.
- I didn't do it either.
- [Kelly] Yeah. You were skating.
- I was a skater.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes. I wasn't very
professional, but yes,
I was a skater.
I skated from four to 17
(audience cooing)
until I went to theater school.
- That's a skater. Four to 17.
I'm like, I did it like once a year
with all my friends and we fell down.
Like nobody actually ever did it.
- [Rachel] Right.
- Did you actually have a real dream
of wanting to do it professionally?
- I did for a time. Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- When I was younger. Yeah.
And funny enough, I hit puberty
and everything goes somewhere and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, it's like doing
jumps was like (groaning).
- Yeah. Well those are hips.
- When I'm swinging myself
around the ice the way I was.
Yeah. But-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- but no, you know, to become a, you know,
a champion ice skater, you have to start
really, really young.
It was like, okay, you wanna do that,
you move away from your family.
- [Kelly] Mm.
- And you get tutored
on the ice every day.
And this, I was gonna do pairs skating,
so I would have, so there was another boy,
he was nine, we were both nine years old.
I was like, he will
become your everything.
- Wow, it's like an arranged marriage.
- [Judy] What a commitment.
- Like an arranged marriage.
And then we won't really
know if you're any good
until you're about 14
when you both have gone
through puberty and we see
if it's all still working.
- Who would, who says
yes to that opportunity?
(guests laughing)
That seems like not a fun time.
- No, I was like.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you were like, no.
- I'm okay.
- When did you know you wanted to act?
When did that hit you?
- I was pretty young. Yeah.
I was probably about seven or eight.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I wrote my parents a letter
saying I wanted to be
on Ed McMahon's Star Search.
- Yes. I was in a later
version. (laughing)
I was in, yeah, American Idol.
- Yes, yes. You were my dream Kelly.
- I didn't know I wanted to sing though.
Like everybody sang where I grew up,
so I didn't really know
until I was like a teenager.
Like I was like 13.
- [Rachel] Really?
- Yeah.
And I was just like, and
I knew I liked to sing
but I didn't know I could
actually do it, you know,
from small town.
- As a job.
- Yeah. So that's incredible
to know that young.
You knew very young as well, right?
- Yeah, I did.
- You're still young. (laughing)
- I am. Yes.
But both my parents are
both actors as well.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I would go into
their auditions with them
and I would sit on the producer's couch
and I'd just watch them and be like.
And then one day when I
was about three and a half,
I was just like, hey, I wanna do this now.
When can I get an audition?
Please get me with your agent.
- See, you and my daughter.
- Yeah.
- So they got me with their agent and
I went up for a commercial and I got it
and I had to sing a little
song about Chevrolet.
And it was on my fourth birthday
and I shot it on my fourth birthday.
So my birthday is my acting anniversary.
- Your first paying gig was at four?
(audience clapping)
- Yeah. (laughing)
- [Rachel] I didn't know that. Wow.
- That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- So, Judy, did you
ever wanna' be anything
other than a writer?
Did you know from a young age?
- I never wanted to be a writer.
- Wait, what?
- What? I never knew that
was even a possibility.
Never. I loved to read growing up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it never occurred
to me that, you know,
that these people who wrote
the books were living-
- Off of that, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- real people. No, no.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- No, it never occurred to me.
- What did you, what
were some of your dreams?
Like, or aspirations?
- I wanted to be a cowgirl.
- Okay.
(Rachel and Abby laughing)
You can still be one.
- I can still be one.
And I never rode a horse,
but I had a bicycle.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And you know, if that was my-
- [Kelly] Just call it a horse.
(horse galloping)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Right.
- You should, wait, You've
still never rid a horse?
Now?
- I know. I've never-
- Don't say you won't. You should do it.
- Pony rides. I had
pony rides in the park.
- Oh, okay.
I was gonna say no,
it's an amazing feeling.
Yeah.
- [Judy] Yeah.
- That's a really cool thing.
- No, but my stepdaughter
has lots of horses.
- Oh, okay.
- Many horses.
- [Kelly] She's an equestrian.
- So I have
- [Kelly] Okay.
- horses in my family.
- Okay, hop on one one day.
(Judy laughing)
Just saying.
It's fun. Stay on though.
I have fallen off and my tailbone.
We are here with Rachel McAdams, y'all.
(audience cheering)
Abby Ryder Fortson, and Judy Blume.
The new movie is called
Are You There God? It's me, Margaret.
It's in theaters tomorrow.
And there are some points in the movie
when Abby's character deals
with a group of friends
that almost feels a
little like Mean Girls.
So, Rachel, my favorite thing
that I say on this show is I love,
you're one of my favorite
actors of our generation
because you go from Regina
George to a detective
to a mom in this movie,
and you play a wide range of characters,
which I find interesting.
Are you purposeful with that?
Like in choosing what
roles you choose to do?
- I try to be.
- Yeah.
- I think it lends to better performance.
You know, if you're not bored,
you're not repeating yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah, (indistinct)
- There's, you know, you're like,
I don't quite understand this.
I'm gonna' have to work
really hard to figure it out.
- Yeah.
- And you know, for me,
variety is the spice of life.
Like I'm not a creature of habit at all.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Love to go around the
world, see different places.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Eat something different every day.
I'm just, that's just the way I'm geared.
So, and like you said,
to get to live many lifetimes in one
is one of the best things that,
I don't know if you feel
that way as a writer as well.
- You do.
I was just gonna' say
that's, when you're writing,
you are living, you know,
you are having all of these experiences
and you are living other lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- And in a way it's like acting, you know?
- Right.
- Because I, when I was
young, I wanted to be an actor
but I never trained or did anything, but-
(Abby laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Writing fulfills that
because I am every character.
- Mm-hmm. I think writing songs, same way.
Yeah.
Even if it's about you,
it's like different chapters of your life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that writing is so therapeutic.
Is that one of the reasons
why you love to write?
It's therapeutic for me.
- It was, it changed my life
and it saved my life and-
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- came long at just the right time.
- Yeah.
I feel very fortunate 'cause
not everybody has that outlet.
And I feel very fortunate-
- Yeah.
- to have.
- It was great for me.
It was-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- It's great for us too, it turns out.
(everyone laughing)
Yeah.
Thank you as well.
But we need a break.
We've got more of our,
Are you there God? It's me,
Kelly, a Judy Blume, oh.
(heavenly music)
- [Male] Yes, Kelly. I am here.
You've been calling my
name a thousand times
during this hour.
You're blowing up my DMs over here.
(everyone laughing)
I ain't never heard
people say my name more
in a concentrated period of time.
Now I'm busy over here looking
at funny cat videos on Instagram.
What you want?
- Oh my God.
It's the voice of God,
everybody. You're welcome.
- [Male] That's right. Finally.
- It's the voice of God.
- [Male] It finally worked.
- Well, I'm sorry,
that's just the title of
our show today, so I didn't,
so I didn't mean to call you.
- [Male] Oh.
- I mean, I always want you around, man,
but actually while you're
here, I do have a question.
- [Male] Sure.
- Why did you make mosquitoes
and why did people lie
and say they weren't in
California when they were.
- [Male] Mosquitoes? Hey,
everybody's gotta eat, right?
Those are God's little blood suckers.
(everyone laughing)
We like to call 'em lawyers up here and,
but I'm really sorry about that.
I apologize.
- Yeah.
- [Male] You know what, from
now on, no more mosquitoes.
I've eradicated them all.
- Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Male] Thanks to you Kelly.
- Okay, one more question though.
- [Male] Yes.
- Do you have anything
you'd want to bestow
upon our audience today?
Do you have anything?
Knowledge? Anything cool?
- [Male] Well, I do indeed, Kelly.
It is a special surprise for
everyone here in the audience.
You are all getting a
pair of tickets to see,
Are you there God? That's
me. It's me, Margaret.
In theaters, April 28th.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much, Lord.